Programming your 2011 2015 Ford Edge key
fob is straightforward. First, ensure
your Edge is unlocked with all doors
closed. Have your replacement fob ready
and optionally a working original. New
aftermarket fobs cost $ 20 to $50. The
programming involves cycling the
ignition from off to run repeatedly
while pressing the lock unlock buttons
on the fob. This process synchronizes
the fob with your car's receiver module.
It may take 5 to 10 minutes and can
program up to four fobs. If the process
fails, check for signal interference or
try disconnecting the car battery for 10
minutes to reset the module. Remember,
these fobs use radio frequency signals
around 314 MHz, so ensure compatibility.
If pairing fails, ensure you're using a
genuine or OEM equivalent fob, as
counterfeit fobs often won't work. The
fobs use rolling codes for security, so
unauthorized duplication isn't typically
a concern. However, incorrect
programming attempts can drain the car
battery or trigger anti- theft mode. If
issues persist, an OBD2 scanner can help
diagnose problems. If your fob got wet,
attempting DIY repair can damage your
BCM. Professional help is recommended.
While newer Ford models utilize
smartphone-based keys, physical fobs are
still reliable for 2011 to 2015 edges.
DIY fixes can save $100 to $150 compared
to dealership costs.